the indictment of former president
Donald Trump promises to mix up the race
for the Republican Presidential
nomination we are still more than two
months away from the first debate in the
Republican presidential primary and
already we can expect to see a crowded
stage this week the number of candidates
swelled to more than 10 and more
contenders may still enter the field CBS
News senior White House and political
correspondent Ed O'Keefe has a look at
where the 2024 race now stands
they go after a popular president the
indictment of former president Donald
Trump is part of the reason other
Republicans keep jumping in to the race
for the White House
many of them have done so with similar
looking launch videos writing the ship
requires restoring sanity to our society
often featuring stock footage of Meadows
mountains main streets and amber waves
of grain as of now there are at least 10
better known contenders former vice
president Mike Pence former New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie and North
Dakota's Governor Doug burgum declared
this week joining Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis former governors Aza Hutchinson
and Nikki Haley South Carolina Senator
Tim Scott businessman Vivek ramaswamy
radio talk show host Larry Elder and of
course
Trump
he still leads the pack by double digits
and he's relished the growing field
that's a good thing isn't it I think
pretty good but I don't think it matters
uh I don't know why people are doing it
they say they're doing it because
they're no fan of President Biden I mean
obviously we see what's happened with
Joe Biden who can't seem to get anything
right or they think some opponents are
too focused on cultural issues we need a
leader who's clearly focused on three
things economy energy and National
Security
or because they think nominating Trump
again would mean another loss for the
GOP a lonely self-consumed self-serving
mirror hog
is not a leader and a country that
Anyone who puts themselves over the
Constitution should never be president
of the United States but there are
disagreements on what should happen next
to Trump some like Hutchinson think he
should drop out others question the
Justice Department's focus and what
we've seen over the last several years
is the weaponization of the Department
of Justice against the former president
and for Republican voters eager to
nominate anyone other than the former
president there came a warning this week
from someone who could have been a
contender
New Hampshire Governor Chris sununu a
trump critic had thought about it but
took a pass because he fears larger the
GOP field gets the more likely it is
Trump will come out on top given where
the polls are right now every candidate
needs to understand the responsibility
of getting out and getting out quickly
if it's not working if we do what we did
in 2016 you're going to have somebody
win this nomination with 35 percent of
the Republican support but even more
candidates May soon join the race
especially if support for the former
president starts to slip in the wake of
the recent indictments that would be a
big change however from how Republican
voters usually react when Trump gets
into legal trouble
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Ed O'Keefe
Washington